jean pierre raffarin est l'invité cette
semaine de preuves par 3 bonsoir
monsieur raffarin bonsoir et libre au
sia merci d'être avec nous et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors que
l'exécutif est dans la tourmente
l'elysée comme matignon votre expérience
bien sûr de premier ministre face aux
crises et au désaveu de l'opinion vous
donne les clés pour analyser la
situation actuelle même si elle est sans
précédent puisque jamais un chef de
l'état n'avait connu pareille
impopularité avec nous ce soir nadège
peljak de l' agence france-presse notre
partenaire avec dailymotion et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat d'abord
jean pierre raffarin comment est ce que
vous qualifiez le climat actuel à la
fois sociale avec la coalition des
mécontents et politique bon c'est un
climat de désordre il n'y a plus
vraiment de repères plus beaucoup
d'autorité et au fond nous sommes dans
un grand désordre ce qui veut dire que
beaucoup de choses imprévues peuvent se
sortir de cette situation
question vous redoutez par exemple la
violence ce qui est à craindre
aujourd'hui c'est la violence on sent
que il y avait une phase de grogne nous
avons prévenu nous avons dit à plusieurs
reprises l exécutif attention à la
grogne il est clair qu'on passe la
grogne à la colère et on va passer de la
colère à la violence si rien n'est fait
pour apaiser le pays on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des
mécontentements qui sont au fond
dispersée qui ne sont pas forcément
identiques et les agriculteurs d'un côté
les artisans il y à tous ceux qui sont
matraqués par les impôts il y à tous
ceux qui sont victimes de la
désorganisation de l'éducation nationale
avec la nouvelle organisation du temps
pour les enfants donc toutes ces
mécontentements là sont en train
progressivement de s'agglomérer de
s'unifier s'était accélérée par la
dimension bretonne qui a la région le
territoire a servi de fédérateur
d'autres fédérateur peuvent venir un
accident un plan social un accident
économies de quelque part et on sent
bien là que la colère peut enflammer
donc qui peut dire de la violence est ce
que vous estimez que françois hollande
est dans une impasse aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il est dans une situation il
doit agir l'institution les institutions
la constitution d'un cinquième
république permet au président de la
république d'intervenir de multiples
façons il a des outils institutionnels
alors lequel lequel préconisez-vous mais
très franchement c'est au président je
n'ai pas de conseil à lui donner mais
d'abord ce que ce que je sais qu'ils
demandent leur appel au peuple ni en
animant un changement de locataire à
matignon qu'elle le dit le pire c'est la
non-action le pire c'est d'attendre je
pense que les socialistes se sont mis
dans la situation où ils attendent d'une
part que la conjoncture soit inversée
attendre la relance qui viendrait de
l'extérieur ils attendent que la courbe
du chômage soit inversée et puis sur le
plan politique il laisse un certain
nombre d' impasse s'installer avec une
majorité qui est incohérente les verts
les communistes le front de gauche les
sociaux-démocrates on voit bien qu'il y
à là plusieurs lignes politiques et donc
quand on attend dans le désordre le
désordre passe dans le pays et c'est ce
que les clubs le critère de la station
actuelle quand il faut un électrochoc
je pense qu'il le président doit
infléchir sa politique économique je
pense que c'est autour de la politique
économique que aujourd'hui s'exprime le
plus grand mécontentement c'est à dire
sur deux sujets l'emploi et la fiscalité
l'emploi c'est la compétitivité l'emploi
c'est le soutien aux entrepreneurs c'est
tout ce monde du bâtiment aujourd'hui de
l'agroalimentaire de tous et tpe de ces
artisans qui sont légitimement 13
étranglé par le manque de soutien aux
entreprises donc d'un côté l'emploi de
l'autre côté la fiscalité faire en sorte
que la france active ne soit pas
étouffée comme injectant un changement
de politique donc une nouvelle
orientation et pourtant le cap semble
avoir été fixée jean pierre raffarin c
celui de la politique de l'offre par
exemple que l'on présente comme
favorable aux entreprises et puis je
note en concernant le budget que josé
manuel barroso juge que le projet et qui
va être votée est globalement
satisfaisant aujourd'hui avec les
économies annoncées donc ce qui ne
satisfait pas les français n'est pas
satisfaisant donc on peut pas avoir ce
mécontentement
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez que dans
très peu de temps on va importer du lait
en france que ça coûte trop cher de
produire du lait en france on va perdre
notre production laitière quand vous
voyez que les constructions de logements
se sont effondrés quand vous voyez donc
qu'il n'ya plus pour le bâtiment de
travail pour l'agriculture de
perspectives on sent bien que la colère
monte alors si les socialistes
continuent à penser que tout va
s'arranger avec monsieur barroso ou je
ne sais quoi ou avec quelles influences
de l'extérieur moi ce que je vois c'est
que le monde est plus tôt aujourd'hui en
train de ralentir je vois que dans un
certain nombre de pays émergents il y à
un ralentissement de la croissance donc
je vois plutôt des signes qui sont des
signes inquiétants même si je vois bien
ici ici ou là quelques signes positifs
mais il est clair que la politique
économique aujourd'hui n'est pas adaptée
à la tente des entrepreneurs et
notamment des pme dans le pays et ça
c'est la grogne la plus grave parce que
c'est la grogne de la france active et
n'oublions jamais que la grogne devient
de la colère ça c'est l'étape
d'aujourd'hui est que après la colère
c'est la violence des voix s'élèvent
même à gauche pour réclamer un
remaniement jusqu'au premier ministre
dit malek boutih est ce que ce serait de
nature selon vous jean pierre raffarin à
redonner de l'oxygène au président de la
république mais ça sept présidents
vraiment de décider je veux pas que
jouer
quelqu'un que dans l'opposition n'a pas
donné un conseil à donner au pouvoir ce
qui est très clair c'est que moi je vous
dis il faut changer de politique
économique et pour le faire il faut
incarner une nouvelle politique
économique donc ça passe par une
incarnation de nouvelles têtes au
président ses rangs politiques une idée
un projet doit être incarné doit être
personnalisé parce que c'est ça la
communication moderne c'est quelqu'un
qui porte un sujet qui porte sa vérité
qu'il explique au pays c'est donc une
incarnation d'une politique donc cette
politique nouvelle doit être incarné de
manière nouvelle alors que ce soit à
l'économie et aux finances que ce soit à
matignon tout 500 c'est la boîte à
outils du président à lui de décider ce
que je dis c'est que le président a les
outils nécessaires mais ce que je crains
lui pour tous et la non-décision ce que
nous pouvons craindre aujourd'hui c'est
au fond le statu quo c'est la tente moi
je pense que le président devra agir
avant les municipales si son idée était
datant des municipales pour agir je
pense que le pays ne lui laissera pas ce
temps là il devra agir avant le
printemps prochain c'est donc en
novembre en décembre qui sont les deux
mois difficiles de l'agitation sociale
et moi très franchement je ne suis pas
favorable à l'agitation sociale et quand
je vois des casseurs et même si ce sont
des gens dont j'ai apprécié quelquefois
leurs revendications je n'apprécie
jamais qu'on casse quelque chose dans
notre pays et je pense qu'il faut avoir
le respect de ce que nous avons pu
construire les uns et les hôtels y
compris quand il s'agit de radars et
donc je pense vraiment que il faut faire
très attention à la violence et je pense
que là le président doit mesurer que les
mois de novembre et de décembre sont des
mois historiquement dangereux pour
l'agitation sociale mais l'agitation
sociale dont elle est aujourd'hui aussi
forte et en même temps potentiellement
aussi violente parce que beaucoup de
colère dans le pays je pense qu'il est
de son devoir d'apc le pays voilà donc
avec une nouvelle politique avec de
nouvelles têtes pour l'incarner vous
craignez le statu quo jean pierre
raffarin mais françois hollande ce qu'il
n'a pas raison quand il le rappelle ce
week-end que la république ne doit pas
céder aux pressions mais il a raison que
l'autorité c'est cela le problème c'est
que si on n'a pas d'autorités c'est la
pression qui impose la seule façon de
lutter contre les pressions c'est de
faire preuve d'autorité mais l'autorité
c'est aujourd'hui de comprendre que la
france active et blessé par une
fiscalité qui étouffe et par des
contraintes et notamment une
bureaucratie insupportable il doit
comprendre cela et moi je suis inquiet
parce que j'ai le sentiment que depuis
2012 les socialistes ne donne pas
vraiment le sentiment qu'ils ont compris
l'ampleur de la crise comme si il
suffisait de virer sarkozy pour chasser
la crise eh bien ils ont chassé sarkozy
mais au regard des la crise et ça ils
semblent comprendre que trop tardivement
aujourd'hui jean marc ayrault a accusé
le patron des députés ump christian
jacob de remettre en cause la légitimité
de françois hollande il a parlé d'un
gouvernement fantôme et même d'un climat
de fin de règne vous vous n'allez pas
jusque là on vous avez entendu bien sûr
que non même si les notations chez
certains parmi vos amis de remettre en
cause la légitimité du programme
scolaire non il s'agit de respecter nos
institutions et donc comme on respecte
le 11 novembre comme on respecte les
radars et comme on doit respecter les
fonctions de la république donc moi je
ne suis pas pour le désordre je suis au
contraire pour un dialogue social mais
dans le cadre de l'ordre républicain
donc ça je pense que je ne donnerai
jamais raison aux acteurs du désordre
mais il est clair qu'il faut regarder
derrière soi et je dirai clairement
balayer devant sa porte aussi c'est que
il est si aujourd'hui on est dans cette
situation c'est que là nous vers nantes
d'autres pays n'est pas aujourd'hui
satisfaisante pour le pays et donc je
pense que le gouvernement doit tenir
compte de ses propres erreurs et nous
dire en permanence qu'ils ont raison et
que ça va s'améliorer que la courbe du
chemin va s'inverser que la croissance
va revenir tout ceci ce sont des propos
qui n'ont pas de crédibilité sur quelles
actions concrètes opérationnelles
le gouvernement peut-il s'appuyer pour
avoir de la crédibilité s'il veut de
l'autorité il faut qu'ils aient de la
crédibilité pour avoir de la crédibilité
il faut s'occuper du chômage
c'est-à-dire développer une un projet
pour l'emploi et s'occuper de la
fiscalité est ce que pour vous une
nouvelle politique signifie le départ
des écologistes du gouvernement ça je
pense que les écologistes pose un
certain nombre de problèmes à la
majorité je pense qu'une ligne politique
mais le problème c'est que le président
doit choisir je vois que la ligne
communiste la ligne écologiste est ici
au sénat les radicaux de gauche et
socialistes quatre familles politiques
quatre lignes différentes donc le
problème c'est que le président
choisisse mais à ne pas choisir il se
met aujourd'hui dans la situation
d'impasse dans laquelle il écrit dans
l'impasse le désordre dit vous n'allez
pas jusqu'à évoquer un délitement de la
situation aujourd'hui qui pourrait
s'aggraver
ah je pense que la situation s'est
terriblement aggravée depuis un mois moi
ça fait à peu près six semaines que
j'alerte sur la montée de la violence de
l'exaspération je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans une situation d'extrême
désordre et qu' il ne faut pas jouer le
pourrissement dans ce genre de situation
je pense que les socialistes ont un vent
contraire terrible il faut qu'il mesure
bien et si dans cette situation il ne
sous-estime l'ampleur de cette forme de
désagrégation y compris dans notre
société je pense qu'ils ne seront pas au
rendez vous de la crédibilité qui sera
la source de leur autorité il n'y a pas
de crédibilité dont il n'y a pas
d'autorité est ce que certains à l'ump
ne joue pas parfois avec le feu par
exemple on voit plus d'une cinquantaine
de maires de votre parti aujourd'hui
qu'ils annoncent qu'ils refuseront
d'appliquer la réforme des rythmes
scolaires à la prochaine rentrée mais ça
je pense que le gouvernement devrait
comprendre que sa réforme est quelque
chose d'impossible et donc là c'est
vraiment une forme de provocation on
demande plus sommaires et on leur donne
moins qu'il faille faire des économies
d'accord mais si on leur donne moins de
moyens il faut leur demander - d'action
on peut pas leur dire d'un côté vous
allez avoir de nouvelles responsabilités
et puis diminuer les les moyens et au
fond il ya là une profonde injustice
naturellement que la mairie de paris
peut donner des cours de chinois des
cours d'art japonais à des jeunes mais
dans le milieu rural
mais bien sûr suédois dans les ghettos
noirs dans les grandes villes
on peut avoir ses moyens mais dans une
petite commune de 450 habitants qui a
deux classes de maternelle ils ont pas
les moyens d'assumer cette réforme est
donc je pense que cette réforme a été
mal pensée et donc le milieu rural est
aujourd'hui en très forte bully sion
contre cette réforme on va le voir au
congrès des maires ou j'assure que la
grogne va être forte comment est ce que
le premier ministre doit être accueilli
au congrès des maires selon vous dans ce
climat je pense que il faudrait mieux
qu'il envoie quelques messages
d'apaisement avant car s'il y va dans ce
climat là il est clair qu'ils ne soient
pas accueillis chaleureusement la
personne de monsieur euro et respecter
l'homme et estimable mais il est clair
aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des maires à
plutôt un sentiment d'échec de cette
réforme quand je vois j'ai vu une
dépêche de la grande maison qu'est la
fpc bien je vous rappelle justement
récemment qui disait que 90 % des mères
étaient satisfaits moi j'avais ce
jour-là à poitiers une réunion des
maires c'était 90 % qu'ils n'étaient pas
satisfaits eh bien je vois cette dépêche
je lis la dépêche dans le détail et au
fond je m'aperçois que c'est une étude
du ministère de l'éducation
donc il ya quelqu'un qui a fait cette
étude sont inquiètes sans doute voulu
plaire à son ministre donc le ministère
dit au ministre notre politique est
bonne et d'un seul coup le ministre
apporte la preuve de la politique est
bonne c'est moi qui suis ministre j'ai
le soutien de mon ministère donc ça
c'est franchement des démonstrations qui
tourne un pont et qui donne le sentiment
que finalement le gouvernement est sourd
aux critiques et aux appels à la
responsabilité des territoires sachant
que moins d'une commune sur 5 1 est
revenu à la dernière rentrée à cette
semaine de quatre jours et demi jean
pierre raffarin c'est les sondages sont
catastrophiques pour les écus tiff il ne
frissonne pas pour l'opposition l'ump en
effet ne tirent pas avantage de la
situation contrairement au front
national les français semblent
convaincus que la droite républicaine
est loin d'être prête avant d'accueillir
nadège pull jacques de la grande agence
france presse s'intéresse à ras le
constat dressé par jérôme rabier
ce serait un scénario catastrophe pour
un président acculé une dissolution de
l'assemblée qui l'amènerait sans doute à
cohabiter avec l'opposition mais à l'ump
on a du mal à envisager un
bouleversement politique si rapide je
pense que la dissolution n'est pas prévu
pour pour demain même des preuves à
faire fonctionner
le propre d'un grand parti politique
c'est d'être prêt à toutes les
opportunités on n'y croit pas mais on
s'y prépare donc jean françois copé à
d'ailleurs prévu un séminaire en
décembre puis un conseil national en
janvier pour présenter un projet
d'alternance que le président de l'ump
se verrait bien porter mais lui non plus
n'est pas au zénith dans les sondages
loin de là l'affaiblissement de la
gauche ne profite pour l'instant pas à
la droite le mécontentement est telle
dans le pays que en reliques et vous
verrez dans les prochains sondages que
tout le monde perd tout le monde perd
des points donc personnes en profitent
d'effectivement c'est ce qui veut dire
que la situation est très très grave et
si dissolution il y avait la guerre des
chefs pour l'instant mises en sourdine
aurait de grandes chances de redémarrer
chacun continue en effet de jouer en
solo à l'image de bruno le maire qui se
posent en présidentiable ce week-end
dans le journal le monde souhaitant la
création d'un nouveau modèle pour la
france et décline en de nombreuses
propositions personnelles sans leader
naturel et sans encore de programme
l'ump pourrait paraître peu préparés au
centre en revanche jean louis borloo en
parle depuis déjà deux mois on considère
cette option comme une forte possibilité
vous seriez prêt uni solution avec un
programme un projet mais oui on a une
réunion de contrats gouvernementaux t4
semaine on est évidemment prêts
évidemment à 80% en est pressée on se
prépare à cela depuis des mois et des
mois il est avec marine le pen le chef
de parti qui semble plus le souhaitez en
revanche l'ump apparaît encore trop
affaiblie et divisée pour envisager
gouverner dans ce contexte économique et
social très tendu le cadeau pourrait
aussi se révéler empoisonné
voilà jean louis borloo qu'on avait à
l'instant et qui réclament aujourd'hui
un changement de cap comme vous jean
pierre raffarin ou un retour aux peuples
n'ont
pas écouté je crois que la dissolution
ne se fait jamais par choix elle se fait
parce qu'elle est imposée donc peut-être
que monsieur hollande sera obligé de
faire une dissolution un jour mais je
crois pas au cynisme de quelqu'un qui
ferait une dissolution simplement pour
laisser le position gouverner pour
ensuite reprendre le pouvoir le fond de
la faire c'est qu'on fait une
dissolution quand on n'a pas le choix de
faire autrement
vu que la gauche va mal vous l'avez dit
et pourtant la droite elle a pas l'air
d'en profiter alors à votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait que votre qu'on
fasse pour redresser son image très
franchement la vème république c'est
d'abord l'exécutif qui compte vous savez
monsieur hollande a été élu surtout
parce que monsieur sarkozy a été battue
donc dans l'opposition on est dans la
situation pour ou contre les socialistes
donc de toutes façons beaucoup de gens
qui sont contre les socialistes
aujourd'hui hésitent à venir directement
pour nous parce qu'au fond les
socialistes sont effondrés beaucoup
prévu on a rarement vu un pouvoir un an
après être élu elle s'y bat donc il est
clair que nous après une défaite il ya
forcément un certain nombre de séquelles
il faut naturellement sur les personnes
mais aussi sur les idées reçoit l'été
tout ça donc nous sommes en
convalescence tout sommes pas prêts mais
au fond on ne s'attendait pas à ce que
les socialistes soient si bas si vite
c'est un peu ça notre note problème je
n'ai pas pris un
petit peu la question que j'avais vous
poser maintenant en cas de dissolution
j'ai bien compris ce que vous avez dit
qu'ils n'avaient pas de raison qu'ils
aient une discussion tout de suite enfin
on peut penser qu'ils n'auraient
peut-être une plus tard est ce que la
droite elle est prête à gouverner elle
avait ça il est clair que s'il y avait
une discussion la droite aujourd'hui
serait en mesure de gouverner on a
suffisamment à l'expérience de la france
il ya un certain nombre de personnalités
dans notre pays qui ont l'expérience des
responsabilités gouvernementales
donc on pourrait gouverner mais disons
que pour nous aujourd'hui nous nous
respectons les institutions nous
respectons la légitimité j'ai vu qu'on
disait qu'on mettait en cause la
légitimité du président on met pas en
cause évidemment la légitimité du
président donc pour nous l'échéance de
l'alternance n'est pas demain matin mais
il va de soi que on a un certain nombre
d'idées et s'il ya six mois j'étais aux
responsabilités demain matin je peux
vous dire que je ferai des choses demain
matin par exemple en supprimant les
seuils de 50 et 200 pour les entreprises
ça coûterait rien
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui ont
assez d'expérience autre chose qu'aux
étages du code du travail c'est pareil
par exemple on peut faire des choses
très rapide et donc tous tous à dire
qu'il ya suffisamment de gens dans l'ump
qui serait capable de le faire mais pour
nous l'échéance est un moyen terme et
nous y travaillons et bien j'allais vous
vous posez justement la question de
saison un petit peu de politique fiction
la dissolution a eu lieu
jean-françois copé est à matignon
peut-être vous même et alors qu'est ce
que c'est donnez-nous les trois les
trois grandes réformes de mettriez
immédiatement en place pour ça et mieux
moi je pense que le premier point ce
serait sans doute un grand accord
franco-allemand de convergence je pense
que ce serait quelque chose qui serait
important avec une intégration d'un
certain nombre de compétences ce que
j'appellerais un bloc fédéral par
exemple comme l'agriculture ou la
recherche des sujets qu'on pourrait
mettre en commun avec les allemands tant
que ça je crois que ce serait un axe
premier je pense que là que ce second
serait sur l'emploi et donc sans doute
on reviendrait sur le dispositif des 35
heures soit par une généralisation de la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires soit par une autre
réforme pour récupérer ce que nous
coûtent tous les ans les 35 heures c'est
à dire mathéa milliards au budget donc
je pense que ça ce serait le deuxième
volet est le troisième volet serait sans
doute une des décisions concernant
l'immigration où je pense que nous
pourrions limité pendant une certaine
période fortement l'immigration pour
concentrer tous nos efforts sur
l'intégration des immigrés donc on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui il ya besoin
d'intégrer des immigrés il ya sans doute
là à une réforme à faire avec nos amis
européens a proposé ce qui a déjà été
lancée comme idée ce qu'on appelait en
schengen 2 c'est à dire un nouveau
partage d'une politique d'immigration il
ya un certain nombre de sujets comme ça
il y en a beaucoup d'autres que l'on
pourrait on envisager assez bon et bien
compris monsieur raffarin tout à l'heure
où de lisier s'était pas à vous de
donner des conseils au président de la
république 1 il est urgent mais
n'empêche que si vous pouviez si les
deux conseils que vous lui donneriez en
tous les cas c'est juste ce que vous
feriez vous s'ils avaient une
dissolution et si vous arrivez au
pouvoir moi je pense que le plus grave
de la situation actuelle c'est les
divergences qui sont en train de se
créer avec les allemands je pense
qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde moderne ce
qui est en train de compter ce sont les
pays continent c'est le brésil c'est la
chine c'est l'un de ces la russie ce
sont des pays continent et nous notre
continent au fond c'est l'alliance
franco allemand bien sûr il ya les
autres pays européens mais le franco
allemand fait continent quand on est
ensemble on pèse économiquement le poids
un continent et donc je pense qu'il n'y
a pas d'avenir si on sépare les intérêts
de l'allemagne
l'intérêt de la france et donc une
harmonisation fiscale budgétaires sur 10
ans moi je ferai un bloc fédéral c'est à
dire je prends 34 compétence va discuter
combien en accord avec les allemands et
on fait un programme de convergence sur
dix ans et on se dit en disant on aura
des systèmes sociaux fiscaux budgétaire
très voisins et à ce moment là où on
fera continent et on sera un acteur
mondial majeur lorsque vous nous dites
sur le dialogue franco-allemand enfin la
convergence franco allemand c'est très
intéressant mais à l'ump n'êtes pas tous
d'accord avec ça parce que vous vous
êtes du courant donc vous animez le
courant humaniste moderne et humaniste
très fédéraliste et à côté de ça on a le
courant populaire par exemple de
monsieur mariani qui lui est
complètement souvent souverainiste est
ce que c'est viala l'intérieur d'un même
parti politique d'avoir des positions
aussi antagonistes mais écoutez monsieur
seguin qui était un leader y compris à
la tête du rpr il avait voté contre
maastricht chez moi j'ai voté pour donc
dans le passé on a déjà eu ce type de
débat c'est pas la première fois où on
sait que monsieur séguin ça c'est pas
très bien pas joué 1 19 mais il n'était
pas le seul à avoir voté dont je crois
que françois fillon avait voté non à
maastricht ça l'a pas empêché d'être le
premier ministre y compris d'un
président nicolas sarkozy qui était très
européen donc je pense qu'on peut
surmonter un certain nombre de clivage
mais si vous voulez me faire dire que
l'ump n'est pas aligné c'est vrai que
l'ump parce que c'est pas un bloc
monolithique mais non c'est pas un
produit d'abord c'est la fusion des
libéraux des gaullistes des centristes
donc il ya des cultures différentes et
c'est vrai qu'à des sensibilités en
matière d'europe il ya des sensibilités
mais c'est pas nouveau vous souvenez de
madame mal à s'effacer veille et
monsieur pasqua s'était pas
d'aujourd'hui qu'il ya c'est que c'est
une question d'ambition personnelle qui
s'entrechoquent c'est plus grave encore
peut-être je pense que c'est qu'elle
s'est quelquefois un peu plus grâce ici
on oublie la gravité du pays et aussi on
oublie ce mot clé que ministre ça veut
dire serviteur c'est ça la police est
finalement c'est pas c'est pas cette
ambition j'entends souvent dire ce qu'il
faut c'est le vouloir c'est celui qui a
le plus d'appétit qui gagnera moi
j'aimerais bien que de temps en temps on
donne le sentiment qu'on aime plus la
france que la politique car l'objet
d'amour c'est pas la politique c'est la
france alors on parlait des ambitions
michel vous parlez des ambitions
justement comment ça se passe maintenant
à l'ump moi j'aimerais bien savoir être
une petite souris la pire garder un
petit peu comment ça se passe chez vous
en interne nous allons vous raconter ça
vous avez des réunions tous les mardis
matin tous les mercredis matin le bureau
politique le mercredi le comité
stratégique le le mardi comment ça se
passe entre riyad les fillonnistes ici
l'écho pays si si là les non alignés
chacun se regarde en chiens de faïence
c'est bel et bien terminé c'était il ya
non c'était en novembre 2012 1 vous
histoire est-ce que c'est bel et bien
terminé
cette pratiquement terminé il y est
clair que et de temps en temps il ya des
tensions qui reviennent mais globalement
par exemple ce matin donc il y à jean
françois copé à sa droite
françois fillon jean françois copé
intervient en premier françois fillon
intervient après en face il ya jean
pierre raffarin et jean claude gaudin et
christian jacob donc nous nous
intervenons plus il ya un tour de table
et on détermine un peu les grands thèmes
de la semaine et on détermine notre
programme de travail donc de temps en
temps il ya un wauquiez qui dira il
faudrait que qu'on est quand même les
comptes qu'ils soient présentés plus
souvent de temps en temps on a quelques
petits soucis
j'ai cru comprendre qu'ils avaient des
problèmes justement dit c'est bien mais
vous parliez des comptes il paraît que
les comptes de l'ump justement ça va pas
très fort écoutez ça va de mieux en
mieux quand même parce qu'il est rentré
les rentrées oui ce temps mais c'est
dans le rouge mais c'est dans le rouge
mais naturellement le financement de la
vie politique est faite au nom de
répéter on a eu une chute du nombre des
députés un très important donc c'est sûr
que quand vous avez été au pouvoir et
que vous êtes dans l'opposition vous
avez une chute de vos financements donc
il faut progressivement adapter vos
moyens vous nouvelles recettes donc on
est dans cette situation mais les choses
vont bien de ce point de vue là dire
qu'on est dans le plan qu'on a mis en
place avec les banques alors s'il
revient en travaux est ce qu'on peut
envisager ce meeting commun qui avait
été proposé mais je veux rappeler par
françois fillon alors françois fillon a
dit qu'il avait proposé à monsieur copé
monsieur copé a dit fait
qu'effectivement il en avait parlé
c'était quand même un petit peu floue
que peut-être monsieur juppé n'est pas
tout à fait d'accord on n'a pas très
bien compris oui ou non il y aura-t-il
un meeting commun avec des membres
ac on a remplacé cette idée de deux
meetings par un séminaire qui aura lieu
le 18 décembre qui sera un séminaire de
type gouvernemental sur des sujets très
précisément place du meeting à la place
peut-être qu'il y aura pas ce qu'on va
tourner les uns et les autres dans les
élections municipales n'ont peut-être
que nous nous retrouverons ici ou là
mais le fond de la faire c'était de nous
mettre tous ensemble pour des raisons
d'emploi du temps pour avoir monsieur
juppé pourra voir monsieur copé pour
avoir monsieur xavier bertrand pour
avoir madame pécresse pour avoir
monsieur gaudin et tout ça puisque les
citer tous mais on a choisi des 3 3 tout
le monde tout le monde sera là à 18
ans sera le 18 décembre que l'ensemble
de l'équipe de l'ump sera là pour
préparer notre projet de réponse aux
aspirations des forces vives du pays la
france active alors justement cette
réponse je monsieur copé d'ailleurs tout
tout tout le bureau politique avec lui a
proposé un conseil national début 2014
je crois vous allez préparer lors de
votre séminaire du 18 décembre avec
présentation des grandes lignes d'un
programme d'alternance mais est ce que
c'est le bon timing avant les
municipales
ça revient pas un petit peu a
nationalisé les municipales ce qui peut
quand même être un petit peu délicat
c'est un débat que nous avons eu je vois
que vous êtes très bien informé je ne
suis pas surpris mais c'est en effet un
débat que nous avons eu est ce qu'on
doit nationaliser les municipales ou pas
et donc nous avons choisi de faire un
conseil national à partir d'un certain
nombre de propositions comme celle qui
sortiront de notre séminaire sur la
france active des entreprises
l'agriculture et c'est cette france
dynamique est aujourd'hui et qui
notamment on a vu se plaignent beaucoup
en bretagne ce sont des propositions que
nous allons aligner certainement que ce
ne sera pas la présentation globale d'un
projet d'alternance mais ce sera les
premières mesures qui nous paraissent
les plus importantes qui savait que vous
nous avez cité de l'or par exemple par
exemple et donc on aura à la fois la
présentation des candidats c'est
statutaire d'ailleurs puisque les
investitures sont validées par le
conseil national et puis nous aurons des
interventions politiques et nos grands
leaders seront tous présents et donc là
il y aura déjà des perspectives
annoncées mais ne sera pas la
présentation du projet d'alternance
parce que nous ne voulons pas donner le
sentiment y compris aux français que
nous souhaitons couvert de gouverner
demain matin nous sommes prêts à
gouverner si nous devions gouverner mais
nous sommes pour le respect des
institutions et donc le moment venu
l'ump sera organisée avec ses idées ses
équipes pour assumer ses responsables le
moment venu c'est quoi 2015 après les
élections municipales elles ont d'abord
gagné les municipales puis européenne
puis ensuite des régionales dans là
dessus mais savent pas si facile que de
gagner les européens ni les municipales
les européens je vais vous parler du
front national et peut-être de nicolas
il reste deux minutes ont dû aller vite
alors une minute bon alors nicolas
sarkozy est ce que vous voyez de temps
en temps ce qu'il a envie de revenir
j'ai déjeuné avec lui je dis je les
trouvais assez en forme en fin de saison
ça veut dire que si les circonstances se
présentent il n'est pas impossible qu'il
puisse revenir mais il a il a compris
que et ce n'était pas pour lui à une
sorte de parcours politique mais c'était
une circonstance que si le pays avait
besoin de lui il serait là pour répondre
à cette attente et en attendant il ya me
françois fillon lui il espère bien avoir
la place mais selon vous le trouvez en
ce moment les cieux fillon parce qu'il
ya eu un petit peu d une baisse de
régime la cedh vient le temps je peux je
pense qu'il a fait quelque chose qui
était assez douloureux qui était de
faire un peu son acte politique
fondateur en prenant ses distances avec
nicolas sarkozy
et cet acte là il en avait besoin et
maintenant il va reconstruire sa
stratégie moi je ne suis pas pour que à
l'intérieur de l'ump on critique nos
couples présidentiels on se fait appeler
ça un carré d'as il est clair que
nicolas sarkozy pourrait être un autre
candidat si les circonstances s'y
prêtent s'il le veut aussi le peut il
est clair aussi que françois fillon bâti
son projet veut entre en résonance avec
le pays laissons le faire ce projet et
nous verrons bien s'il ya résonance
alain juppé s'ils gagnent bordeaux et si
son expérience
il va pour il va probablement gagner
bordeaux et donc si alain juppé le
souhaitent il a les compétences c'est et
jean françois copé le quatrième parce
qu'il tient le parti du président du
parti et donc là on a un carré d'as nous
verrons bien encore comment s'organisent
des chemins primaire 2015 2016 qu'est ce
que vous dites bon on verra la primaire
à mon avis vous savez qu'il avance mais
d'ailleurs wauquiez
à 2015 c'était ma dernière question pour
jacques 3000 très franchement je trouve
que le quinquennat est déjà trop court
si en plus avec les primaires on
accélère encore le calendrier ça fait
précipitation donc moi je suis pour 2016
réponse merci
maintenant jean pierre raffarin on va
revenir avec vous sur l'enfer de
matignon vous l'avez connue même si
c'est aussi l'enfer à l'elysée malgré la
protection institutionnelle dont
bénéficie le président sous la vème
république vous l'avez rappelé il y a un
instant tenir c'est le maître mot comme
le rappelle sophie normand y aurait-il
une malédiction matignon ces anciens
locataires sont unanimes la fonction est
infernal parlementaires mécontents
opinion qui ne l'est pas moins presse
versatile jean-pierre raffarin a connu
ça aujourd'hui c'est au tour de jean
marc ayrault au couac en série
revirement dissensions au sein de la
majorité s'ajoute le désarroi des
ministres inquiet et frustré pas évident
dans ces conditions de tenir le cap face
à la tempête il y en a au moins un qui
croit stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture proche de françois
hollande
aujourd'hui face aux difficultés qui
sont les nôtres et bien il ya une règle
absolue qu'il faut observer et gardées
c'est la solidarité et la solidité parce
que 50 à sion méthode coué rue du
faubourg saint-honoré l'ambiance n'est
pas moins morose les conseillers visés
entouraient le blues difficile de
travailler avec un françois hollande
solitaire qui ne sait pas dire non
entretient le flou compte il ne tranche
pas par sms directement auprès des
ministres sans en avertir son entourage
victime collatérale de ces problèmes de
gouvernance interne l'ensemble des
troupes socialistes elle qui réclame un
chef et rêve d'une majorité organisé
tenu face aux difficultés à
l'impopularité bertrand delanoë n'a
qu'un conseil pour françois hollande
tenir bon
interrogé l'ancien premier ministre et
son expérience qui a déjà traversé pas
mal de tempête gouvernementale on a
beaucoup parlé de l'incompétence de
l'inexpérience du couple exécutif c'est
vrai qu'ils n'ont jamais été ministre
les deux françois hollande jean-marc
ayrault est ce que c'est cette
inexpérience ministérielle qui se paye
aujourd'hui à votre je pense en partie
oui je pense que pour le président de la
république ça doit être difficile de
présidé le premier conseil des ministres
auquel il assiste je pense que quand on
n'a pas vécu l'appareil d'état mais
c'est vrai aussi du premier conseil
européen c'est vrai d'un certain nombre
d'instances où ça doit être difficile de
trouver sa place quand on n'a jamais été
présent dans l'instance donc je pense
que ça fait c'est une partie du problème
ça c'est une mise en route difficile de
mise en route difficile mais que sont
des gens intelligents et qu'ils
apprennent vite donc ça devrait être
assez vite corriger mais moi ce qui me
frappe et par rapport aux reportages et
notamment par rapport à ma situation
c'est que moi j'étais dans une un cas de
figure où c'était le premier ministre
qui était exposée aux mécontentements
dire je menais la réforme des retraites
je menais et donc j'avais le président
pour me protéger à la fois de protéger
le président des mécontentements et en
même temps quand j'avais besoin de
soutien de validation le président
venait en soutien de son premier
ministre venait en appui aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière le président est
presque plus bas que le premier ministre
qu'il peut pas aider le premier ministre
et oui et on fond le premier ministre ne
protège pas le président parce que c'est
le président qui est critiquée dans le
pays donc normalement dans la 5ème
république quand ça fonctionne bien
c'est le premier ministre a critiqué le
président est plutôt protégé mais là
c'est le président donc le président ne
peut pas vraiment ni s'appuyer sur son
premier ministre ni le premier mis sur
le président en fait ces deux hommes là
je trouve se ressemblent trop ils ne
sont pas assez complémentaires ils
viennent de la même cour en politique a
même histoire ils ont pas d expérience
très différente et je trouve que ils ne
peuvent pas jouer ce système de
complémentarité qui jouent généralement
dans la vème république que moi j'ai pu
jouer même s'il y avait des difficultés
mais avec un jacques chirac et rpr quand
j'étais udf qui était plutôt parisien
quand j'étais plutôt provincial et sait
où on avait des profil un peu différent
mais on avait une complémentarité alors
oui à ce qui est dit solidité solidarité
mais dans la complémentarité et non pas
dans la ressemblance des réflexions
rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
d'une part sur la complémentarité par
exemple françois hollande déjeuner
aujourd'hui avec martine aubry profil
différent
donc plus complémentaire par rapport à
françois hollande je pense qu'elle est
qu'elle a une complémentarité évidente
avec françois hollande est donc là elle
peut apporter un certain nombre
d'initiatives d'abord à l'expérience le
mental est là étaient dans l'appareil
d'état et puis elle a une connaissance
internationale est elle a le profil
c'est une femme de qualité d'évidence
donc c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui peut
avoir le profil de ce type de
responsabilité qui sera utile au chef de
l'état aujourd'hui c'est à lui de la
presse il m'a dit
mettez dans la situation où je serai le
consultant du président ce qui était
assez difficile pour moi il m'arrive
c'est bien martine aubry jusqu'au bout
j'avais initié notamment au dossier
chinois mais c'est quelqu'un qui est
très respectable et qui a beaucoup de
qualités donc en tout cas en tout cas un
profil en tout cas elle a la dimension
de la fonction alors après est-ce que
c'est utile ou pas utile ça dépendrait
quelle politique et il peut faire mais
c'est quelqu'un qui par exemple s'il y
avait une politique économique un peu
différente et elle pourrait à la fois
calme et peut-être la gauche de la
gauche et en même temps orienter les
choses de manière différente je ne sais
pas si c'est ça qui pourraient être
proposées mais en tout cas la
complémentarité pour être joué comme un
atout cette première en son genre le
grand autre réflexion par rapport à ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est
vrai que le quinquennat le fait que les
calendriers parlementaires et
présidentielles soient maintenant les
mêmes a beaucoup changé les choses à
votre avis non je pense qu'il ya une
accélération très ça efface le rôle du
premier ministre par rapport à celui du
président la république c'est ce qu'on
avait reproché à nicolas sarkozy l'ultra
présidence il gère présidence je pense
que françois hollande avait annoncé
qu'il reviendrait un peu une pratique
plus traditionnelle de la vème
république mais en fait il a marché dans
les pas de nicolas sarkozy en s'exposant
de trop je pense que le président doit
se protéger en mettant trop premier
ministre en première ligne c'est ça la
cinquième réplique c'est ça le génie de
ces institutions du général de gaulle
dont on sait que la france est un peu
monarchique mais elle est aussi régicide
donc le monarque ce le président si on
veut le protéger il faut qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui soit le fusible qui est
celui qui est exposée la colère du
peuple il doit agir il est exposé et lui
en même temps qu'il est protégé par le
président il bénéficie du fait que le
président étant à peu en retrait peut le
soutenir dans les périodes difficiles or
aujourd'hui ce système de vases
communicants et de solidarité
complémentaires n'existe pas ils sont
tous les deux en difficulté avec des
sondages qui sont identiques et il y en
a pas un sur lequel l'autre que ses
pulls et autres alors françois hollande
peut encore décider de se retirer
justement
président et sans gouverner directement
je peins carnet rose je pense que
françois hollande a les outils
institutionnels de sortie de crise ce
que je crains c'est qu'ils soient dans
un attentisme commune et sur le terrain
de l'emploi en dix ans la courbe va
s'inverser il attend et ce faisant la
situation pourrie et donc la gravité de
la situation me fait lui dire attention
monsieur le président la situation est
grave derrière à la colère et à la
violence dans leur attention un petit
mot peut-être sur ségolène royal je
voulais vous faire réagir elle a
qualifié le mouvement des bonnets rouges
de mouvements citoyens réconfortant
est-ce que par ces mots elle se
disqualifie pour entrer au gouvernement
éventuellement je pense qu'il n'est pas
question pour le moment quatre ans
gouvernants puisque le président voulait
que les gens qui avait été élue elle n'a
pas été élu au législatif donc ce serait
revenir sur son engagement donc même
madame royal a le sens du paradoxe
politique pour pouvoir exister
médiatiquement et donc elle nous a fait
preuve encore de son talent paradoxal un
mouvement réconfortant donc la levée des
bretons c'est ce qu'elle a dit c'était
je pense que elle cherche toujours à se
distinguer elle y réussit quelques fois
françois bayrou a annoncé la semaine
dernière qu'il serait candidat aux
élections municipales à pau vous dites
oui non bien pas bien
nous verrons comment les choses se
présenteront en tout cas moi je ne fais
pas des centristes mes adversaires je ne
fais pas de de quelqu'un
on va voir ce que le parti va décider on
va voir ça mais spontanément comme cela
en tant que politique et en tant
qu'humaniste l'ump terre centriste de
l'ump je ne fais pas des centristes
l'adversaire je trouve qu'il ya d'autres
menaces dans le pays aujourd'hui que
monsieur borloo et monsieur bayrou donc
ce ne sont pas remboursés surtout de
france mais
alors premièrement je pense qu'il ya
d'autres adversaires que ceux ci
deuxièmement je reste un bon chrétien et
que celui qui revient dans la maison du
père est toujours bien accueillis dont
qu' aucune raison
en tout cas en ce qui le concerne je
pense qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
d'important dans cette entente entre
françois bayrou et jean-louis borloo
et que le centre est arrimée à droite et
nous les humanistes de l'ump c'est un
point clé de notre pensée politique il
faut arrimer le centre à la droite et
c'est ce qui a été fait donc pour moi
tout cela et et une plutôt une bonne
nouvelle c'est que ces majoritaire comme
penser au salut mps que tout le monde
est prêt à pardonner à françois vaillant
aujourd'hui je ne le pense pas j'ai
rencontré récemment été le cas je sais
comment je vous parlais tout à l'heure
il n'apparaissait pas être sur cette
ligne là d'accord donc tout n'est pas à
manger pour françois bayrou la peau non
non je pense qu'ils iraient beaucoup de
gens qui considèrent que c'est un
symbole et qu'ils ne veulent pas
pardonné à françois bayrou mais moi si
je me projette un peu avec de la
distance savez quand on a perdu les
élections présidentielles et qu'on veut
les gagner le prochain coup il faut que
des gens qui ont voté pour françois
hollande votre pour nous le prochain
coup donc celui qui a voté hollande si
on commence par le condamné ça veut dire
qu'on n'espère pas son vote le moment
venu donc je pense que ceux qui ont voté
hollande équivalent vote et maintenant
pour nous il faut qu'on puisse leur dire
qu'ils sont les bienvenus donc soyez
charitable à l'ump c'est ce que voulait
leur dire je voulais
revenir à l'exécutif quand deux
ministres emblématiques sont un peu
perdus de vue je pense à manuel valls
aussi à arnaud montebourg est-ce que
c'est une bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle
pour le premier ministre et le présent à
un public enfin c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle parce qu'ils ont un capital
dans l'opinion ils s'en servent que pour
mm alors que le premier ministre aurait
besoin ils devraient s'investir dans la
bataille mais là il se protège et donc
puisque ça va mal puisque c'est la
tempête ils sont mis à la cape l'année
l'autre donc ils ne mettent pas leur
capital de sympathie à la disposition
collective donc c'est cette ce sont des
épargnants égoïste et les
îles et ils ont épargné leur popularité
et maintenant ils veulent la conserver
pour eux mêmes et pas pour le collectif
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'habituel dans tous les gouvernements
les ministres l'illustré bien sûr les
ministres les plus populaires restent
bien caché quand ça tangue mais
la solidarité le bal frais qu'ils
devraient investir leur capital de
sympathie pour essayer d'en transférer
un peu sur le premier ministre pour
terminer votre réaction à cette
considération de dominique de villepin
sur la politique il a dit l'elysée est
un pas les fantômes être président c'est
finalement passé la journée à faire
semblant de prendre des décisions il est
désabusé l'ancien premier ministre ou
c'est vrai au jeu je pense que désabusé
je pense que cette une situation et qui
exprime pour lui sans doute à la fois un
peu de salle j et puis un mal-être
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que symbole a
beaucoup d'importance et c'est vrai que
le symbole n'est pas toujours perçu par
tout le monde et que le président à des
actes symboliques mais je pense que
la fonction présidentielle en france et
une fonction de de première importance
et elle est majeure et aller elle
demande beaucoup de concentration et
beaucoup de force la preuve c'est que
tout le monde n'a pas l'air capable de
la de l'assumer dernière question de
finir ce que vous avez le blues comme
beaucoup de sénateurs ici je pense blues
non pourquoi le blues parce que certains
ont l'impression que le sénat ne sert
plus à rien de ne pas peser dans le
débat public c'est vrai que le scénario
est pour moi le sénat existe quand
président du sénat s'oppose un peu à sa
majorité au sénat le sénat c'est une
tempérance le sénat c'est une capacité
de corriger un peu la politique qui est
menée donc c'était ce qui est de la
situation la configuration de sarkozy
larcher s'était la situation de hollande
belle ce sont des situations où le sénat
pourrait jouer un rôle de tempérance de
modération un peu de fric d'inflexion de
la politique ce qui n'est pas
suffisamment le cas merci
avec nous cette semaine merci perrine
bonsoir à tous et à très vite